i've seen so many youtubers get so
sucked into their discord yeah um and
you know i've this is why i said it way
way back you know my number one piece of
advice is to not make a discord server a
public discord server which is why we
haven't made a trash taste discord
server yeah which even though people
have asked yeah it's the my number one
piece of advice to any youtuber because
it's it's a time sync you know managing
a discord server luckily now i i don't
manage it i've got i don't i don't go on
there like yeah i i play i mean i post
updates and you know you know people
understand it now yeah
but you know i remember when i first
started stepping back from it i would
get a lot of messages being like i can't
believe you aren't active that's so
so wrong it's your discord so you should
be active it's like what would you want
to do do you want me to sit here and
message you so so the other two million
people can't have a video like yeah yeah
yeah you want to take time away just so
i can i can i can laugh at the meme you
sent me like
[Music]
kitten lord xd you know what i was
trying to do i actually had to coach
sydney through this because she actually
like had i think she had like a public
discord and you know at the beginning
everyone wants to interact with it's
great it's great it's great everyone
wants to interact with their fans as
much as they can and it got to the point
where cindy thought that
if she didn't do it then people would
think that she was ungrateful yeah for
for
you know the attention or for like for
them supporting her channel yeah i'm
just like and she grew to a point where
she was waking up just stressed she was
waking up and she was like i've just got
so many notifications yeah and not me me
too yeah yeah and it was like she woke
up and for a full like month i think she
was just depressed because she didn't
know how to handle
everyone trying to get a piece of her
attention i'm just like look you've got
to because because this was this was
back when like this is back when she
started to you know kind of get a bit of
a bit of momentum all right and and i
like luckily she had me to like coach
her through it because i literally had a
go like a head coach because i was just
like look you've gotta just get past
this point where you just gotta realize
that it is part of the job and part of
the job is just understanding that you
can't give everyone attention i know you
want to i know it kills you to show
everyone how grateful you are for their
support and everything but it's
physically impossible for one person at
a at a certain size yeah like if someone
meets me in person and uh you know if
they want to speak to me i'll gladly
speak to you as you know
anything
we'll talk yeah and i would rather that
so much more than a message through the
screen i don't know it literally doesn't
mean anything when you're watching
through it like discord yeah you don't
know the person i'm like i don't even
know who you are like they are over here
bro i don't know what's going on
honestly i think like the best way to
just have a casual conversation is
it i mean you can't plan it which is
unfortunate but if it's it's mostly
conventions right yeah if you see us at
a party at a convention or just like
hang on we look like we're just not
heading somewhere or like busy then
we'll probably have time to like have
like a quick chat or something yeah
that's what i want to go and the quick
chats are always the best yeah and some
and sometimes you meet an interesting
character and you're just like yeah we
should you should hang out later you
know at one of the parties that we're
going to or something like yeah yeah
i've had people i'm like yo come on yeah
yeah exactly right
yeah yeah but like
unfortunately that's just not something
you can plan you know we're gonna we're
obviously gonna find it creepy if
they're gonna be like okay so uh this
person's gonna be here at this
convention and he's gonna be here here
here i can say hello here
and uh
so we have to rendezvous right here
no because like i've had a really weird
okay kind of like strange
um evolution of like interactions now
that trash stasis started right because
obviously the world hasn't opened up yet
but i've now met like a few people
post trash taste that has just been like
so like we've met in like a normal
social situation so it's just been like
at a friend's party or like some kind of
gathering but uh they're like yeah i uh
i watch trash taste and the first thing
they say is like i i i know about the
parasocial relationship thing but like
i'll just say it up front and like i i
understand that there's like a
difference between
knowledge between what i know about you
and what you know about me and i'm just
like this is actually really weird
because i think that's the best way to
handle it just just like acknowledging
that yeah they're an active viewer and
they know more about me than i do about
it yeah i'm just a meeting they're like
i might like you but i know you're not
my friend yeah yeah yeah so i'm just
like so i'm just like cool let's close
that gap then so did you see the clip of
uh felix talking about it
he he someone asked him like do you know
connor that he was like yeah dude he's
like yeah what's trash taste it's weird
i feel like i know them but i don't know
them at all yeah
that coming from felix
like i feel weird i feel like they're my
friends but i've never spoken
i was like that's
saying great yeah
that's the thing like if felix is saying
that then [ __ ] everyone is
susceptible to him
don't feel guilty don't feel guilty you
know the big boss man himself yeah
like the thing i'm trying to say is we
don't know how to handle it correctly as
much as you don't know how to handle it
we're all [ __ ] we're all [ __ ]
interested it's a very strange situation
we've all found ourselves yeah yeah yeah